if you're a fan of mine congratulations
don't watch riff and regret
hey listen they probably don't anyway
[Music]
you want to do a press run of what
i'm going to do
uh leno
i'm gonna do
he only does uh the car one i'll stop
his car i'll do it you're gonna go in
his cars and then just
talk about your ferrari yeah i got one
he would probably laugh at both of you
and he has so many cars right
oh he bums me out because every sunday i
go the malibu cars and coffee right with
my son and he's always there and he
pulls up in a tesla
[Laughter]
and i'm like what are you doing dude are
we did we start yet yeah
yeah
we're live let me tell you something
right now we're live we're live um so we
started we don't start with like a hey
what the hell is going on now there's a
whole intro all right well let me tell
you something about this okay yeah um
teslas
no
no that's it it looks like we're too far
we're way too far no that's why we i
know but we airborne but
um teslas look like they were built on a
factory in effect and i know they all
are pretty much but like a lot of cars
but like no just i don't like them and
it's it's like teslas
why do you have a dancing there we go
eric what are you doing you know
so i'm sure i got an electric jag man
okay i don't think about it i wouldn't
even know what it looked like
i don't want to spend 150 a gallon for
my you know and you're in your ferrari
we can thank your lord and savior biting
for that
hey don't look at me with that [ __ ] you
pray you've always in
of what whatever trump did with china
now that we can't get a new car yeah
the transportation's like dicey yeah
you know i'm sure it happened
there was some guy out there i almost
didn't say it but i didn't
tell you what happened in my brain i
thought
chips and then i thought no not chips
and then i thought i'm gonna say i'm
gonna say that and i thought well i
don't want them to think i'm making a
fat joke but then i thought but i'm not
though
so i should just be me and say it and i
said it and then this [ __ ] took
it as a yeah yeah it was also you just
said it in his house it was in a fat
joke
my mind was doing all sorts of sifting
dude okay trying not to disrespect
the guest the co-host really yeah who's
the guest me i'm the guest you're the
guest but you disrespected the co-host
you know what you did you know what you
did within five minutes of being here
fat shamed air
unreal dude there it is there it is
unreal
you know what i did fat shame
but i'm sure like when back back in the
day was like steam powered cars and [ __ ]
and when they went to gas there was guys
like me who were like ugh no way it's
not get out no you were still on your
horse like what are you guys
[ __ ] bad he was just still running
like they're [ __ ] losers dude let me
let me tell you something though dude
it's not the fact that it's electric
it's that it doesn't look good okay you
know what look good i'm 100 with you
that's why i didn't get a tesla i don't
like i don't like that i just don't
understand make an electric engine and
so take a ferrari yeah and put an
electric shield in it and make it look
like what are you doing wait like
pre-remember prius
what are you doing what about the leaf
you want to talk about jesus bro i don't
even know what that nothing drives you
girl up more than a leaf and [ __ ]
crop it's called a leaf
it's called a leaf well the leaf comes
with crops it comes with a free pair of
crocs and hugs no [ __ ] that crocs come
with a
leaf dude that thing was disgusting yeah
dude don't call your car the leaf that's
it wow but also tim dillon made this
point tesla's it's like this weird like
cult too like you've got a tesla it's
like this weird cold thing well the
technology like they think they're
better than everybody it's awful yeah
because they're what you're saving the
environment dude but the engine but
first of all the batteries in them like
you know how they mine for those yeah
i know i don't know it's whatever you're
saying right now sounds like the
beginning of something that would be a
conspiracy theory and i just i already
don't know
so i don't have a clue what you're
saying but um there's a lot of great
electric cars coming out though yeah
when
when what i'm with you electric cars
about 10
is all we got look at the electric
hummer i want to get an electric car but
they keep pushing it back crazy the
humber looks pretty dope yeah the tesla
truck is kind of dope another company
rivien they got a dope looking car too i
want that they keep pushing it i don't
like the name
yeah i can like do the dug-in [ __ ] yeah
you don't we don't need that but you but
like but everyone's going to electric
like even ferrari like the sf90 that was
half electric that's the river i'm
talking about i like the river
thank
you so i think in 10 years there won't
be another there won't be gas cars
anymore no that but uh california no no
newsome you know people go ahead and
knew something it was another concern
already i think it's 20 35. you know
he's in bed the he's gonna start you
know he's in bed with the what
and you have to do it like that you know
you know
he's with the queen of england no
no but he i think he's he's the first
one to make uh gas-powered cars illegal
in 2035.
wow oh yeah he's not gonna allow the
sale of him anymore which also suck my
dick no i don't give a [ __ ] just make
him look cool i don't care 100 100 pair
i don't care that's when i'm with them
bro they're not going to be cars are
going to be flying eventually like you
don't need to have like those big
engines they're they're gone they're
gonna be gone i had a buddy i had a
buddy when i was in the nfl for
literally three seconds but
he got a big paycheck and he took all of
his signing bonus and this is in 2006
good idea and put all the money into
flying cars
he invested all his money into flying
cars well it might pay off it didn't no
he didn't he works at like ralph's now
wait check this out with a lot of those
nfl players
they should have got enough you you are
a podcast away from having to work at
ralph's right
you have this thing
network
yeah i was bagging [ __ ] groceries at
ralph's
no but there's a company this is how
great the electric cars are going to be
there's a company right now uh one of
these startups that put their battery in
a tesla and it went 780 miles
oh like total or not not not mine one
charge miles per hour oh okay
700 yeah you've got to be clear
well is it an airplane no no no no just
it went just
right into the [ __ ] so that's i mean
that's the future because right now the
problem with the cars
is the fact that you know you can't
really go a good good amount of debt
like like i can't take my car to vegas
and they say 300 miles but that's not if
you're driving like betty white yeah
you're going through but like if you're
is your radio on is the air conditioning
on it's like it doesn't really go
my favorite are people that are like oh
it's touchless i remember brian got he's
like like drives by itself i'm like okay
we're driving to brea and that thing was
[ __ ] if the sun hits it wrong like
veers over to the left he's like oh my
god yeah people have died because they
think it just they can just hit the
button it's gonna cruise control yeah
this goes back to my whole [ __ ] thing
and i always i always say this
don't
make the [ __ ] thing
until it works yes dude you know how
fast remember when remember when louie
was we went nuts that bit on conan went
nuts and he was like stop complaining
you're 30 000 feet in the air because
your wi-fi doesn't work you remember
that bit that went viral anyway there's
a bit that went viral dude i completely
disagree with that don't give me wi-fi
if it's going to be spotty i don't want
to be i don't want it to be introduced
into my life yes unless it
works for it and then it doesn't work
you try to get a refund it's just like
voice texting the [ __ ] don't work dude
i'm tired of it my phone's racist yeah
yeah my iphone when it when he's texting
does it work yeah i'm like well i did
not say that yeah i didn't say that the
[ __ ] oh your phone makes your voice
testing is racist yeah yeah real racist
it could be this is racist too dude i
was standing next to a black guy the
other day my phone goes ill get away
and i don't stand for that dude you know
me i'm way against racism and slavery i
do not i'm not into that
sounds like a conspiracy theory no no
because they're in bed with the [ __ ]
yes yes
dude a [ __ ] callback 10 minutes in
welcome to king of the sting dude we're
here live this is how you got to start
the show dude okay give us the intro how
you doing
here here we go
thursday nights we're coming at you late
at night you're a [ __ ] loser at home
watching this thursday at night king of
this thing here we go brought to you by
congratulations the greatest part
can't do that no i mean maybe if it's
your show
what's this young man want oh this guy
oh let me tell you right now look at
that this guy is often around trees
is 78 to 80 percent
of his life is he is 10 feet from a tree
chopping trees
this guy deserves some congratulations
he's giving us an update he was planning
on proposing to his girlfriend at a
concert
oh oh do we know what concert was josh
combs or he says it on this who's that's
here uh country artist luke combs
let's take a little break from chatting
with the boys of king of the sting cause
listen man a lot of you boys losing your
hair two out of three bros will
experience some form of hair loss by the
time you're 35 more than 50 million
dudes worldwide all right well really in
the u.s we're just talking about the u.s
here 50 million in the u.s suffer from
male pattern baldness and i see it out
on the streets a lot of y'all losing
your hair my friends at keeps offers a
simple stress-free way to keep your hair
convenient super easy you get with a
virtual doctor medication shows up
straight to your door every three months
you never have to leave your crib low
cost starts at 10
a month all right
keeps has more five star reviews than
any of its competitors prevention is
super key here if you want long locks
like my boy mark harley or chris d'alia
treatments can take four to six months
to see results so act right now if
you're ready take action prevent hair
loss go to keeps.com k-a-t-s that's
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash cats to receive
your first month of treatments for free
that's keeps.com cats get your first
month free k-e-e-p-s dot com slash cats
you know my boys here they're proposing
to their girls they're doing all this
stuff man and you gotta come correct and
let my friends at blue now help you out
man bluenow.com you can celebrate all of
life's special moments all right from
creating custom engagement rings of her
dreams or his dreams to gifted a classic
timeless jewelry piece
all at prices you won't find a
traditional jeweler trying to save you
money man trying to get you right there
are two parts to this business wedding
jewelry all right and everyday fine
jewelry and uh we got you covered man we
got you freaking covered whether you're
ready to pop the question or celebrate
your love this valentine's day you gotta
come correct on valentine's day fellas
you gotta shop at bluenow.com
make your moment sparkle with jewelry
from bluenile.com cats listeners and
viewers get 50 off 500. this is a
podcast exclusive it's good only through
valentine's day includes engagement all
right use the code kats that's code kats
plus every order's insured ships free
arrives discreet little package so it
doesn't give away what's inside shop
stress free and find your forever piece
go to bluenow.com today
brandon theo stevie wiebe eric griffin
nick hope you guys all had a merry
christmas that was a nice guy this is
josh from up here in oregon i was
calling to thank you guys man uh last
time i called i had some proposal advice
for you guys and um
you guys helped me out i got that
diamond hitter on my girl's finger she
said yes and she said it was the best
night of your life wow wow he's short
combs
and uh during our favorite song and it
just ended up definitely my best best
night of mine idiot in the back hats
today with some marriage for the kiss
guy in the background her family's not
really around unfortunately um to help
pay for the wedding which is fine um i'm
totally down to pay for this wedding and
work hard and you know get everything
done
but just popped in my head this morning
and was wondering if it's an appropriate
question to take to my fiance and ask
her
if she might be down to get just going
low you know
dude that's the move dude weddings is
correct take the money that you're going
to spend on your [ __ ] wedding invest
in a house or something like that or you
know what honestly invest in flying cars
now is the time podcast network yeah man
by the way how about how good i was was
saying he's always near trees and then
he said he was from oregon come on
you're crazy [ __ ] sherlock holmes i
mean i'm not you watch too much first
48. also you're crazy if you don't think
that guy has calluses on his hands
no no he's first of all i think that you
should get like the the diamond ring and
the wedding take that money and put it
in something
crypto whatever the diamond ring and the
so yeah and
honestly don't even buy clothes there's
that point too but also
we could get a fake diamond dude that
was that i don't even know
the show no no no the the the real the
real g's they go they take it to the
place and be like um can you bro i love
how you called
the women the real g's the real geez
that's good that's good your girl's a g
no because i don't think how much
weddings are bro you know what's going
on i was at a clipper game one time and
i was sitting next to this older couple
and the lady was looking at her ring and
it was like and he the guy goes he was
like hey she just got an extra diamond
in it and he was like they got married
25 years ago and he was like yeah it
cost me 20 000 back then and i said man
imagine if you put that 20 000 in
microsoft
for real yeah and the guy was like don't
get me started and she was like this
pulled out a gun and shot his brain yeah
oh dude she was like i don't care about
that i remember it blew my mind my when
i used to be married [ __ ]
how was it which i still don't believe
87.
i don't believe i never believed that he
was married never believed
dude honestly horrible decision no it
was fine because like i i think that if
you go through a marriage you're [ __ ]
you figure out a lot of [ __ ] you know
what you don't want what that's what i'm
saying if you go through it didn't work
out yeah you know what not to do again
yeah yeah i mean you three or four
marriages then it's like it's maybe not
for you and you did it before you had
stuff yes yes yes yes
so i forget what the [ __ ] i was even
bringing up what the [ __ ] was i bringing
oh you were married before yeah but what
the [ __ ] was that the rain and it was
timber oh oh i blew my mind i mean i was
like 25 but they were like we had a
conversation and all the we were talking
about the guys and the girls and they
were like what what
did you
would you rather a diamond ring or like
a really nice tv and a sound system set
up and and all of the women were like oh
a diamond ring and the guys were like
what yeah it's oh diamond close but
you're surprised by that useful you're
supposed to i was when i was 25 yeah how
did you propose to your to both your
your acts and your current one how'd you
propose uh you put some effort into it
what are we talking about here yeah i ju
i uh did you do it on your podcast
yeah i did it live on my podcast
congratulations brought to you by
congratulations and uh
and riffing
[Laughter]
yeah but my voice was um we gotta do it
again because now i'm ready
you're a comedian
so now i'm ready all right i'm ready
uh i proposed whatever you know i
proposed in the i went you know what i
did on the first time i went into the
well this is [ __ ] ridic this is
actually i never told this story but the
first time i proposed i did it at um
i drove i had i was so
uh nervous and i i took it we went to go
see a movie and i pulled out over and i
i walked in front of the car in the
headlights it was at night and i just
showed her the ring and then she came
out and just started crying and [ __ ] and
that didn't work out yeah do you
remember what movie
yeah you don't know what the movie was
called kicking and screaming
oh with will ferrell yep great soccer
movie no not when they get the italians
yeah how do you remember that movie but
love that movie it came out so long ago
but anyway um
so not much effort there okay so that
didn't work out that sounds awful i
didn't have money i didn't know so then
the second time did we learn yeah jumped
out of a plane uh
well this time
yeah he was yes you had yeah no i
well so we i asked
her
this guy proposed
outside of culver's this isn't my video
is this uh yeah chris wasn't it's you
and your girl yeah yeah that's me and
her
actually before covet but we have masks
it was uh it was i asked her at home in
the beginning yeah i asked her at home
yeah
she said she didn't want anything
special so i did that you really took
that lie
they lie
they she wanted something i said are you
sure 900 times yeah and and i don't
believe her and then so now was that was
uh so then i did it was calvin born
already
uh no but i will tell you this um i did
it that way and then just to do it
also because just in case i asked her
again
to be in a different way in front of all
her friends we were all got nice
pictures taken for all of us because her
friends got together we were in saint
louis you probably had a little outfit
yeah i had to print my outfit was
honestly it was bad i mean i'm just back
you got to be better you got a big thing
we have good photos and so um and so i
asked her again in front of her friends
because i wanted to do it this special
way too so if you asked her if you asked
her which one she'd like which of course
she liked that one better dude exactly
that's what i'm saying so she was lying
all night i understand but she wasn't
like to me she was lying to herself yes
yes dude cause that's what she's doing
i feel like eric one-ups all of us
because you're a romantic do you like
your girl or some [ __ ] no
wow dude take a picture of black and
white take a picture in black and white
of you and put it on a [ __ ] yeah you
[ __ ] up and said black and white
remember yeah black and white oh yeah he
said
why because i'm because i'm being racist
you're saying that was my phone's fault
you everything okay anyway but i propose
you're actually bad though she takes her
ring off at night sometimes and then in
the mornings she wants me to propose to
her again she doesn't love you at night
she takes it off because she doesn't
love you at night she just likes to cry
i love you in the morning
and i do that i don't even warm up
crazy in the morning i'm the only one
that can't sing here yeah i only do
opera well that's nice that's good
that's good but that's honestly dude if
you can believe it i didn't even warm up
but go ahead your girl likes to sleep
single that's what's going on she's a
dream single yeah dream single the new
single
dreams i only love you in the morning
[Applause]
don't get yeah of here bro i know you're
theater trained we got yeah daddy yeah
dude i took [ __ ] three years of voice
lessons you know you know how lazy on
the piano
[Applause]
him and his brother are like those
german basketball players that don't go
to high school they just play basketball
yeah that's what his dad did to them he
said you're going to acting school yeah
no math no english no science tight move
papa no no my dad honestly didn't want
us in the business at all until he saw
me shred the stage dude now that he's in
until he's and i don't say this but
until he saw me shred the stage
anyway dude
you know it's just not a dramatic like
cat's the musical
if you're a fan of mine congratulations
don't watch riff and regret
hey listen they probably don't anyway
[Laughter]
what's up brenda i'm thi ho everybody
else like cats
king understand it for you
he's the same guy forced construction
worker and apparently my grill's all
[ __ ] up
how [ __ ] cool
cavities
okay okay anyway it's a trillion dollars
to get that [ __ ] fixed yeah or just do
you know deal with it until the kids
turn 18.
party wants to look cute but part of me
wants to also like
have money
so it's like you know how [ __ ] up is
it
do people want me painting their houses
looking like this
or do i just like wear a mask suck
let me know
gang gang nitrous buzz
well yeah save your money dude yeah i
don't know how much it is and how much
he has he just showed like for veneers
it's like 10 grand a tooth it's so
expensive oh really so expensive really
expensive well well honestly from here
it doesn't look that good look fine it's
just chipnick or what yeah i didn't
think it was that bad either i think
it's i think that's way worse if he just
has a chip too you can get a filling or
something it's also character like
that's a conversation star like girl's
like having your tooth and you make up
something oh it's chipped a little bit
you're a construction worker
yeah yeah
you don't need teeth at all no i don't
care if you have teeth just do the work
man
go toothless knock them all out that's
not that bad no dude it's not terrible
the bottom is great
i'm sure he loves that we're zooming in
on that
but what is he doing with his money like
you know
yeah what's he doing he's like well
should i get two teeth or
have money to do what would invest in
flying cars man that's what i'm saying
and also you know he's got you know he's
got like a crypto wall at this guy
i don't i don't trust anything about
this dude when i've mentioned my teeth
on the show people have messaged me and
been like if you go overseas or to
mexico you can get it like 10
of the cost and it's like
they're it's good work it's just because
they can't find customers over there so
go to mexico here's what what what about
choose your accent yeah here's the thing
about mexico
they don't have the same like
regulations we have you put some matter
you put mexican teeth in and all of a
sudden you're like
you're like wow these look really good
well you really made them sparkly
it's like home alone oh my god
do we get the chinese teeth but we won't
do that exactly
why because
yeah
it was a bad year for them yeah
yeah we can still make fun of mexicans
now right you know no next year dude so
get it in dude get it in asians blacks
you cannot do it dude
with mexicans no one here is getting on
essa now though anyway that's true
that's true you know what that's true
thanks nick
[Laughter]
uh we got a few more here
a lot of pink in the room christian has
pinkie on your boy has pink on chris a
lot of pink
uh we got a few cats in the wild uh
someone sent in uh theo what he's been
doing with his free time he's been
trying to get jacked in his room
is that theo
that's theo if he was benjamin buttons
and he's just about to die
or like a voodoo priestess shrunk his
head dude
that's theo's little brother still
living with his mom wait what
can here's here's what i think when i
see
that guy why is his wife being so bad i
think
are we allowed to make fun oh yeah no
but you know what i mean like origin his
tick tock is huge so oh it is oh wow
6.5 million likes is it did he have
plastic surgery and didn't finish
you know what i mean like it looks like
he's going through like a transition ran
out of money yes
he invested in flying cars
what is the
what he's trying to get jacked in his
room who is so someone said this in we
do a segment called cats in the wild
when they see someone from our crew that
they think looks like us here's here's
another one here's uh brian kalin on
cops
part time
season 33 bro
you know cops are still rolling cops are
still basically
they stopped it for a little while
they stopped and then fox like on demand
picked it up like the right wing news
picked it up oh wow yeah they're still
rolling that does look like theo and we
got one more someone sent in eric uh
down in florida he didn't like some of
the regulations
once again florida law has taken away
what's my god-given right
it needs to look like me you know what
i'm saying no you know what it is you
can't just have a mustache and glasses
and be like this is eric no i mean you
guys don't have to say
[ __ ] no
you don't mind
if you grab your mustache you're missing
it that's how you sound
well that's different they're taking
away my god he's like thank florida i
can't molest the alligators anymore
we do constantly get people sending in
once they're like oh this is theo and
it's just some guy with a mullet and
it's really bad i don't like it
try harder dude i agree i agree just
like it's like give me a [ __ ] i'm out
of here
uh
a couple more
oh hello hey guys this is jc from
winners california and i have a king
understand for you
i don't know if you've seen that
youtuber partners who goes around
shaming people for not returning their
carts
um what do you think about that like i
always return my car clearly kid is the
best but i don't think i'd yell at
someone for not returning their car
grocery cart um yeah love you guys gang
gang
safe buzz yes
super cute well i don't go to the
grocery store because i'm not a peasant
so
i do but i'm always worried someone's
gonna rap me out i always return the
cart oh wait a minute i get i get super
self-conscious this guy's got a thing
what's he got a bulletproof vest on for
a lot of people say returning your car
is like a test of society whether or not
you're a good person and this guy he's
got a really big youtube channel and
here's his this
guy's already terrible
[ __ ] and i'm the founder of the carton
arcs
carton art sebastian independent
organization that tries to get people to
just take their cart back to the cart
return
when i do see that some lazy bonuses
left their card out i turn on the wand
adjust
the mouth size how does this guy not get
beat up well that's why it's gonna hold
for best one
we've had hundreds of encounters i've
had many threats on my life being a
carton arc besides a guy pulling a gun
on me i've had multiple people say
they're going to run me over
well sir that's not nice yes i'm a
killer
sir that's against the law there's
definitely an adrenaline rush
here's like ma'am cartenark
oh this is my uniform i have an
equipment vest which is actually a
bulletproof vest i put my body camera
right here
capture that what else this guy's lost
lost in life huh
does he also give people tickets for
like you know if you park a non-compact
car in a compact spot you know what i
mean oh dude hey guess what there are no
compact spots
[Laughter]
the parts are
when i see a [ __ ] dude how many
cars are compact i know how many i know
two percent yeah and they have so many
spots there are no
compound i go in with a big car
and i come out and i eke out and i'm
like this dude stephen hawking when i'm
coming out of it dude [ __ ] them
but also they have all the parking spots
for teslas now well that at least at
least
you know it's electric electric
it's really tesla though there's so many
tests no dude that's tesla's the new
like 911 for agents in l.a
like you know how many agents drove
[ __ ] porsche oh yeah
it's it's corny-ish they don't know cars
they're waiting but this guy's a carton
arc this guy like
this this guy's how's he going
he's trying to get [ __ ] well he's gonna
get beat up it looks like he's in texas
too though he's throwing beat up yeah
he's gonna get shot for sure he's gonna
die he's there
i like the spin off a poor guy has a
broken brain he's going to die wow two
hotties in one show yeah it's so washed
out you don't know we know though we
don't know what she really looks like no
she yeah okay
light will come into effect and she'll
compare the guy with her
fight oh yeah
very attractive woman
let's take another little break because
i got a dilemma in my hands man i'm the
only person who doesn't speak spanish in
my house my kids talk trash about me i'm
pretty sure my wife talks trash about me
but you know what i got a little secret
up my sleeve i got babble that's right
babel i'm trying to learn a new language
with babel it's the language learning
app that sold more than 10 million
subscriptions i'm learning spanish right
now that's right don't tell the fam i'm
learning spanish right now the whole
babble process is freaking fun it's fast
it's easy babel teaches bite size
language lessons for real world use
babel's 15-minute lessons make it the
perfect way to learn a new language on
the go i do it in my car before i drive
home man all right other language
learning apps use ai for their lessons
babel lessons created by over 100
language experts you're getting the real
you're we're talking real accents all
that stuff man with badly can choose
from 14 different languages including
spanish your boys learn spanish french
italian or german there's so many ways
to learn with babel in addition to
lessons you can access podcast games
videos stores even live classes plus it
comes with a 20-day money-back
guaranteed start your new language
learning journey today with babel right
now when you purchase a three-month
babble subscription you get an
additional three months free that's six
months for the price of three just go to
babel.com use promo code kats that's
babble.com b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com
code is k-a-t-s babel language for life
oh sure she's nominating her single
friend savannah from dallas and i am
nominating my best friend to be the next
bachelorette of the cats dating game her
name is shelby she's 25 years old and
she lives in austin texas
she is a hottie with a body loves her
cat loves to be outdoors
super funny and smart and she is
yeah dude someone got married yeah no
yeah from here yeah
wow you're welcome you're welcome no i i
know
congratulations this is not a
self-centered podcast congratulations
no i know and that's where you guys are
mistaken because
you know tune in for what i didn't even
forget this [ __ ] but i'll tell you
uh they're gonna get divorced those
people and you know that good chance
right
i feel like that they felt pressured to
get married but carry on oh yeah because
you're [ __ ] famous now right yeah you
don't say yeah you're supposed to follow
the bonafide baddie so now you have to
find her uh
yeah next week we're gonna have a bunch
of submissions of guys who want to date
her and then and then we zoom in and
they zoom in we get to talk to them oh
that's funny yeah welcome to king in
this day all right highly productive
don't make me feel insecure yeah i know
your show one camera uh one camera yeah
one camera one camera one guy so if you
if you want to date shelby or a chance
to talk to her send in your submissions
we do have another a second person who
wants to participate in the dating game
uh
recognize my new favorite why not
why not hook them up
oh this mark yeah that's my watermark is
this braveheart look at that look at the
hoodie too dude sorry strong guys all
right this is braveheart yeah let's do
it
what's up ladies uh my name is mark mark
harley 19 years old
trainer podcaster
but i also played the buff guy in that
cdw commercial so as far as what i'm
looking for in the lady well she's got
to be between the ages of
23 and 57 ideally and must do booty band
glute workouts at least three times a
week as far as what she's looking for in
a guy i need a woman who appreciates a
muscular male form
a frame so jack that some people i'm not
gonna leave any names might consider it
to be bordering unawful looking
you refer to chris
somebody looking at all this and
thinking it it looks awful
i'm cracking up just thinking about it
but if you think
this is too much beef in your butcher
box
don't apply
bro aggressive no he's beefy he's beefy
yeah i just don't like that he has
wizard hair no you know what i mean i
know
i don't know man he looks like this he
looks like yeah he's [ __ ] hilarious
if gandalf you would exactly this is
like gandalf at 25. yeah
oh man but uh he looks like the lion
from onward he's no no no no he's
he's blanca from street fighter that's
who he is yes that's who he is if he
goes like this
no he needs to scrub his tongue too can
we get him a tongue scrubber his tongue
is very white yeah no but let me tell
you something all bodybuilders that are
that big have that they have to have bad
breath like you have to have bad breath
why because the protein no it's just
it's like everything is weird and out of
black you know what i mean like dude his
his
hair
wow dude
he has a [ __ ] mane on him i feel like
girl's gonna come out for him though but
how on it well yeah dude maybe we set
him up with uh that's what i'm saying
austin holland how old is
if you told me he's 55 or or 20 i'd be
like yeah not 20. no bro he looks like
he has two early gray hair which he does
yeah he's 35 yes he's 35 36 great dude
all right we got a couple people looking
for something i feel like we need some
submissions for mark
yeah yeah so if you're a girl and you
want to date mark harley send in a
submission video 45 seconds or under
telling us a little bit about yourself
and if you're a guy and you want to date
shelby same thing or we could just
connect those two or if you're a guy and
you want to date mark hit up
congratulations podcast
that's going to be your dating
engagement
i'll feel those submissions we do only
gay
dating
i guess this guy is great man
it's for straight people but it's gay
and yeah actually yeah if you're a guy
and you want to date mark harley please
send those submissions in as well yeah
yes yes
this guy's uh the wrinkle huh the
wrinkle that he's got brendan
it's like his glasses are stuck you know
what i mean did this guy start out his
day with a punch in the face yeah hey is
this is this guy's mom a sharp hay
what's happening here yeah really jesus
girl he's got it he's got a snazz on him
if that was an [ __ ] you couldn't get
the [ __ ] out no matter how many times
you wiped it you're gonna have streaks
he's that guy he's had a rough year so
he explained so
this guy will be stopping with that
[ __ ] that dude tell us later so we get
all the jokes out you don't have to feel
bad about it
oh that's true or something but what's
up i guess it's hunter from auburn
alabama again wow hunter and this new
year started off pretty rough this bama
team last year on the new years with
kovid so i had to stay at home
then about a week later i got charged
with
shooting into an occupied dwelling and
now i'm facing life
by that i mean my girlfriend's pregnant
i trusted the
on the period conspiracy theory um so
yeah i was just seeing if you guys had
anything especially you brandon since
you've gone through this process
she was on her period
he's just looking for some advice from
someone with from a dad okay me and
chris can do it did he get lip fillers
now you woke up like that man i guess
starts the day with a punch in the face
he's got something he got those dsls
you got to get some hopes on him
he got those
dslrs juicy look
dude
the the
ah for [ __ ] sake this guy is uh all
everything on this guy his hair and his
face and his lips and everything is all
the same color
so he wants to know he has he wants to
know he knocked up his girlfriend he's
just looking for some advice words of
encouragement now those first six months
are gonna be
you're basically uh a navy seal and bud
camp you're talking no sleep yeah okay
but wait hold on though you're missing a
key point here he said he had sex with
her on her period yeah she still she got
pregnant me lied well
she lied
what she was on her period yeah she was
like no you can bust to me i'm on my
period it doesn't matter okay but i'm
saying
you're bleeding if you're around your
period well you listen i'm not a
detective are you are you a no are you a
no period sex guy no i am
really oh yeah no you're not or no you
are whatever it doesn't matter i don't
you know if if my girls aren't appearing
what's what's the difference yeah i
don't care won't do it a heart out why
not really blood
bro you're in a ring are you guys you're
a face punch oh hey i'm sorry ted bundy
no are you [ __ ]
are you shitty
sex that is such a good point though
what would beat the [ __ ] out of people
in a cage
not because i want to see blood but
there was blood you don't have sex
because you want to see blood either get
cracked
okay
just put a towel down oh my god or wait
but it's [ __ ] blood not [ __ ] yeah
are you are we serious are you [ __ ]
with me
[Laughter]
uh i'm inventing a new thing [ __ ] sex no
for that reason i'm out eric griffin
like eric griffin
you freak no that's not everybody
okay morning sex there's all kinds of
smells regardless not
[ __ ] though
oh
dude if you do if you do that and then
there's a piece of [ __ ] that whoopsie
daisy flies out
but you pull out and you look like a you
know a chocolate covered something
around a chocolate covered banana it's
too early
dude don't say what you just said it
shouldn't happen bro you shouldn't have
did you say chocolate covered crawler
what'd you say yeah just it's like i
said chocolate covered bananas yeah
they're like a banana disgusting
chocolate disgusting you just go right
to the shower you don't walk around
nothing like a bloody [ __ ] what about
the stairs
you just you i'm sure you've done some
crazy public [ __ ] no i don't really do
public [ __ ]
dude i'll tell you what man
if you've never been in a car yeah but
that's not publicly like let me get that
that's in the privacy of my car in a
ralph's parking lot
dude hey nick and chin you are you guys
on board with this please don't change
[ __ ] guaranteed
i care about the [ __ ] but the blood i
don't care yeah yeah
that's natural it's natural it's natural
it's once a month that's natural [ __ ]
[ __ ] hannibal lecter over here no
it's not hard
i'm not that's that good i know that's
that's just around your dick it's like
lights off
you know what i'm actually surprised
that you think yeah yeah yeah too i'm
surprising you guys an old [ __ ] mcgee
over here oh [ __ ] i get that no [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's what it is
he gets it yeah you two you two are cool
with the [ __ ]
no no no no no no
hold on
no one's cool with your [ __ ] yeah it's
it's
the point is i'm not trying it's like oh
you're on your period yeah yeah it's not
like well that's what it sounds no no
that's what it sounds like no dude no
but eric is definitely like oh don't go
to the bathroom yet let's just boom
that's you do that dude hey did you have
curry it's backdoor bone yeah also you
know you know
when he's having he's talking about his
own [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah you pull the strap on out no no
dude you're just no not even you're
still having you're not into pegging no
no it's not
no it's not pegging you're with your
girl you're inside her and then you just
go oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] at the back of you will you
marry me that'd probably be right on top
and you're on top that'd probably be
like
that'd probably be like a weird
sensation
you know what it would be
such a release yeah that's what i'm
saying and you'd cry imagine if you come
and [ __ ] at the same time that's
probably really good
um
they would be so disgusting right now
come here i told you i won't be talking
about this [ __ ] yeah yeah theo oh he's
for sure
sex at all right yeah yeah yeah i get it
what's this
uh she's got a debate club for us what
is up today
somehow this
is [ __ ] right here he was like i
think chris is going to be honest
it's usually just all hairy dudes yeah
what the [ __ ] going on here even mark
harley was a hot chick yeah um
for this show yes yeah yeah she's got a
great accent boy hold on before we even
go
what great hair she has yeah this is
amazing yeah who's better here her mark
yeah that's the poll put that pole up
hey guys jacinta j here from melbourne
australia um i'm a longtime listener and
so we've already discussed when is an
appropriate time to start setting up the
christmas decorations but when do we
start taking them down the day after
christmas i see some people you know
they're ready to turf those christmas
decorations on the street the day after
christmas like they're kicking out a
drunk uncle or something but then i see
other people who just want to make the
most of the decorations and they're
still kicking with a christmas doily and
antlers on their car until like february
to mid march disgusting
the holiday the new year's is part of
christmas oh it's the team it's the 10th
[ __ ] year and after the first is when
you take it down eric you've changed
dude christmas till new year's anal sex
this is insane
dude hold on don't forget the blood yeah
i was gonna let that one slide so hold
on
well first of all kristen is it's insane
she's rachel to stuff up yeah say we
were talking about this a little bit
earlier eric and i were talking about
just a little bit before the episode and
i said eric save it don't blow your load
let's talk about this on the podcast
because it's going to be utterly
hilarious okay now um
but kristin will start
so she'll put it up before november yeah
yeah oh you're in that yeah yeah
listen listen rachel had rachel had
halloween [ __ ] up yeah oh sorry kristen
has a skeleton band
that she put you press a button and it's
like
i dig the holiday spirit yeah but once
that holiday's over you gotta adjust
it's over my thing yeah we didn't have
we did have pumpkins in the window a
little bit too long my thing about
kristen is
if you're if you're bringing if you're
expanding christmas that long then it
takes the [ __ ] fun out of the actual
amount of time correct you're just
deluding it right but but yeah elf on
the shelf
we got it this year because it's
exhausting it's exhausting yeah exactly
my chick has a valentine's uh
[ __ ] up right now wow
here's the thing here
we got kids so it makes sense yeah yeah
you don't have any kids yeah she's just
practicing
yeah fair point
training campaign
training camp um yeah i don't know about
this but i think that this is what i
think because i said to her she put it
up before thanksgiving i said what about
thanksgiving uh stuff you know and she
literally said what's thanksgiving she
just loves christmas that much sure that
but but and she's her name is almost
christian she just wants to get to it
she wants to get to christmas and she
loves it and she she loves it and it's
and she loves it if you have kids it's
great yeah oh but also take the tree
down on the 26th archery still no bro
it stays until the freaking first cool
should be january 6th that's the
epiphany when the wise men finally made
it to the nativity 12 days of christmas
tell this fake news
fake news wasn't that the day of the
[ __ ] uh when they stormed the capitol
yeah i'm just saying dude somebody's in
bed with somebody
that's the wise man there you go this is
all awesome and you know and you know
joe biden will never be president you
know that right
this guy's got another debate club for
us yeah this is usually the look all
right let's go crew i got a little
debate club um
so what is worse to have
a super hot mom growing up with
when all your boys just want to bang
your what if it was like or a million
dollars
ugliest mom
to where like you don't want to bring
her out because you're embarrassed oh no
no
and uh all your boys just make fun of
you
like a really ugly mom
you know kids don't let you get by with
anything
let me know nowadays they'll find
anything to make fun of you like you
can't win you can't have a hot mom nor
an ugly mom wow such deeper issues yeah
[ __ ] bust your balls over it wow
anyway my question is my question is was
his mom hot or a warlock yeah i wish he
added that and i also want to look at
guys my mom's probably trying to look
like a guy
i have another stop talking about how
good looking the guys right though
i know i did i did but you said the
other guy had dick sucking lips anyway
and then you talked about anal dude
hold on does anyone listen to this show
that doesn't wear carhartt
i swear to god everybody yeah answers no
yeah
hands a lot of car hearts i don't know
what's better i've i've actually having
a hot mom if your mom's a fighter yeah
if your mom's a warlock you're gonna
probably look like [ __ ] too good i'd
rather have a hot mom you know what i'm
saying well awesome
let's say your mom had when she was
young and then like you know if you had
like a young mom and then she's like
looking
delicious and you you don't want to
listen you don't want any warlock jeans
in your family dude
your kid comes out as a warlock you're
right
i'd rather deal with a hot mom all the
time your friend's like dude i'd love to
titty [ __ ] your mom
you know what i'm saying they always
want to sleep over yeah
you're like man i'd love to [ __ ] your
mom in the butt all right dude that's a
lot yeah i bust all in your mind
just it's you know what it is it's the
way you brought it up no i know it's but
it's the way you brought it up [ __ ] it i
know no but it's the way you do it
see that's the that's the universe right
there
is that theo's not even here and he's
busting me yeah
all right
phil just pressed a button from
nashville uh hot mom all day you don't
want a warlock in your family tree maybe
a good point anybody have a warlock for
a mom though you would know yeah no my
mom's pretty good my mom's cool my mom's
big momma's about 5 11.
wow and my mom big my mom my dunk all up
on you put her titties in your face all
right well okay this guy's getting like
at the same time or
sure you're talking about separate
she'll dunk on you and then after that
you'll have a drink take a shower and
then she'll put her titties all up in
your face
it's different dude it's different and
she'll be on our periods you know what
are we going to do after
it's disgusting
yeah some of these guys are my homies
what do you think about hey hold on
pause is this guy from
1997 is that a tap out
hat an affliction shirt
well what i don't understand is like do
all the cats people just like lazily do
these videos like well i'm on the way to
work so let me just do the video yeah
can we get some effort like like yeah
what do you want him to have a ring
light yeah yeah i want a ring light
look at how the video starts
look at the first frame
it starts on his jinko jeans at least
started on your face no those are
jordans also here's the best part he's
not even is this the passenger seat yeah
he is he's just
driving this guy's just doing this yeah
his friend's like what the [ __ ] are you
doing dude
he looks like rob your dick if rob deer
deck was on drugs yes he actually does
yeah some of these guys are my homies
what do you think about it king
understand it migrant workers at home
depot
[Music]
some of those guys is cool to me i don't
know
and uh
if i'm out of work i'm over there too
you never know
or whatever
yeah
that's eric's because it means [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm gonna pass on this one i'm i'm i'm
definitely gonna pass if i drive because
sometimes you need work and those guys
get that money bro but if there's if
there's a white guy in a tap out shirt
i'm
just mexican just oh you're saying just
some accidents though but get out of
here no lights you're saying it's a it's
a dicey subject to talk about yeah
especially especially the way he brought
it up
he was like i like it it was a little it
was a little like theo ish you know what
i mean
they're still humans to me which made me
feel weird yeah it made me feel weird he
goes i dream like what do you guys think
about migrant workers huh i kind of like
them you know that's like saying i have
a black friend yeah you know what i mean
i don't know i didn't like it which that
guy doesn't have a background
[Laughter]
what's up king in the staying it's uh
blake here wow gonna say hi to you all
but i don't know who's all on the show
anymore fair point just kidding
yeah it's uh negative 20 something
degrees here in wolf point montana and i
am trying to get truck started diesel
fuel has froze
um negative 40 degree windshields
about to get my meal prep in
[Applause]
what
why there's so many bring it with me on
the road
um yeah so king understanding it
negative 40 degree weather heart sting
dude love you guys what are you talking
about who the [ __ ] would king about it
what kind of dumbass king in her
stinging is this king
so hey guys here i am at my house i just
showed up my whole family's dead
somebody murdered him and it's terrible
uh they got stabbed and gassed and shot
in the head and i'll probably be framed
for you i'll probably be praying for it
i
tell you guys before i call the cops so
they're going to say that's weird king
is stinging
getting stabbed in the gut or getting a
million dollars which one do you prefer
like why would you want to live a hard
hard statement
i hate that move for sure move move yeah
uh sting it montana but you have some
good months there montana montana is
great hey dude but have a beautiful day
a year you could have a whole good year
somewhere yeah the worst part of that
video is that noise when you click
i know it's [ __ ] exciting you're like
oh i've been there and it's freezing
but did you grow up in new jersey new
jersey but i'm saying on the road
sometimes you do [ __ ] and you're sure
[ __ ] all right i didn't bump outside i'm
not talking about what's the coldest
place you've ever performed i played in
no i played in um
i played buffalo middle of the winter
and uh it was a snowstorm and i was like
i'm gonna sell zero take it like no it's
buffalo dude they deal with it yeah yeah
people showed up on snowmobiles yeah
yeah yeah
yeah yeah for me it was alaska okay you
wow no i did north battleford way up in
[ __ ] canada and it was just oh yeah
yeah yeah miles montana you got another
one the guy asked me the guy actually
asked me that the hotel was staying out
he was like are you here tomorrow and i
was like what's up i was leaving but i
didn't do it he was like we're gonna go
ice fishing
i was like oh
i'm leaving but and he was like it
actually is really warm in that little
thing because i was like
yeah i don't
if you have to say it's actually warm
yeah yeah that's true you know what i
mean yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
compared to like compared to what you
know yeah but also you ever been to
montreal in the winter
awful mm-hmm oh isn't everywhere awful
in the winter chicago is terrible yeah
chicago sucks like there's seven days
out of the year chicago is nice it's lit
it's either too hot or no it's real
muggy or it's yeah
yeah what's this think you want they all
look the same all these [ __ ]
wait this is the same
it's the same so this is for sure the
same guy it is that
they're all in the same car put the
video up side by side they all look like
roy nelson's and that's our fan base
that's fine i need to see a side-by-side
video of this guy in the last guy okay
also the dude with the big nose even
without he's that's him without facial
hair this is the same guy he shaved his
mustache in one did another video he
says craig this is like yeah wow this is
insane and with the hood too yeah same
color hood it is okay maybe it is the
same guy it is it is winter everywhere
though you know true all right let's see
he's in the car but yeah what's up thong
vaughn and brandon showers what tim here
from south orange county california okay
it's warm there what do you guys think
about those uh midday jaunt hitters at
work what you know we're gonna be doing
a little 30-minute break take a little
punch since everybody here is stupid
yeah
let me know what you guys think about
those mid-day hitters hey man whatever
you guys do i watch the podcast all day
at work
gang gang buzz buzz buzz buzz
whatever gets you through the [ __ ]
day yeah honestly if you're gonna get a
nine to five do whatever you want i love
when people say like i watch your
podcast all day and it's like my podcast
is an hour dude when they say when they
say people people say like i watch
congratulations every day and it's like
no they're that you don't want to leave
every day it's once a week
you don't watch it every day stop lying
well they put it on the channel and then
just like maybe they watch old ones but
they're yeah they're doing on demand
then you know what you're mean huh no i
am me you mean but also specify that to
me
so i've seen them all and what happens
is i play it and i can sit there but i
also don't have your hood up in orange
county you know
that's what happens that's what happens
when you move from i bet you that guy's
from like wisconsin i'm always moved to
l.a and then you get used to it so it's
probably 65 and to him oh i'm always
cold now i'm always cold yeah your skin
looks cold i'm always cold i'm a weird
color yeah yeah i'm a weird color are
you wearing he's just really white i'm a
weird color but bro you're like twilight
that guy's really white he's not a weird
color
correct i'm a weird color you're like
off pink i look like i'm about to die
and that's fine dude i did the [ __ ]
yeah um
last uh
fighter in the companion i did was um
fighter in the companion
that's fine yeah dude just a little
ribbon yeah
it's okay but no fight the last fight
baby people were like oh he
oh he's gonna die
i'm a gray guy you're great i'm a grey
guy you're a gray worm i'm gray so that
guy yeah dude if you got to smoke a
little bit but here's the thing though
some people smoke weed and it's fine
some people smoke weed and they just
they're out of hand
you're like you're like oh dude like i'm
friends with people who smoke weed all
the time every day and and then some
people i had to be like you i do i can't
be your friend anymore but like broken a
smoke weed you have no idea that's what
i'm saying but then there's other but i
don't i don't know anyone that smokes
weed and they
they get mean like no one gets no i mean
no no i drink every day
you're white you're super boy well you
know what it is on the same color as
that shirt yeah what's the deal with
that
my hair is kicking though my hair is
kicking white people aren't supposed to
wear orange and yellow it's bad for
complexion oh you're so right he's from
how has the response been on the neck
tattoo
i mean dude no
with my
like brand of humor and my my fans all
they're going to do is try and like
roast me because they think it's funny
sure so i don't really know honestly i'm
sure there's going to be people i'm sure
they're going to die a bunch of life
rips and all that stuff oh there are
yeah some guy had it i was i had this
schedule then i was going to do it like
in two days and somebody posted on
instagram live rips right here i was
like oh that's so funny
same thing yeah
no tattoos for you eric no
no that's where you draw the line
[ __ ] and blood
i stopped there ill
the next
it's the pain of it
you should get one at the cat's bachelor
party for eric next year
yeah
yeah we do got to do a trip club tattoo
you want to go to costa rica or
something get weird what are we talking
about okay listen rachel is not into
that
i'm not asking rachel yeah yeah but
she's already like if you're the kind of
person that has to go to a strip club
and i'm like well let me tell you
something if there's one place that is a
safe place that we can talk about it
where we know rachel is not going to
listen
right here
right here dude right here so we're
gonna set up your bachelor party oh my
god
are you doing any bachelor party or
anything i won't know yeah look at you
piece of [ __ ] you know you're a little
different with me
we'll do a you know what we'll do a
cancelled bachelor party for him
bingo
i bet as soon as like hey babe i'm
thinking of a bachelor party she goes no
you're not yeah you're right
she goes but you know what i'm all i'm i
don't need to i don't know we could do a
joint thing yeah okay
go to vegas
but don't do it
i'm sure you were a monster at yours
define monster
there's no blood and poop i tell you
that much yeah but there was probably a
few boners just bags just bags of [ __ ]
yeah
hey here we
[Laughter]
go bro how do you how do you manage to
make everything grosser yeah you
i can't believe we just started and you
are like finish him yeah we got bags of
[ __ ] yeah we were throwing [ __ ] like
you're going all the way you're telling
me that you're they're bringing bags of
[ __ ] to my bachelor party and i'm just
saying this is what we're doing with it
yep all right
okay
we're doing we're finger painting have
we set up honeymoons have you done that
no no no no no all right no better no
honey if we're going to kill you guys or
not if we go on a honeymoon we're going
to miss your wedding yeah so i don't
know if i don't know what we're going to
do yet or just do it like dude that's i
don't understand why people have to go
right on the honeymoon i did that right
i did it on my last one and it was like
stressful dude it's a lot to plan it's
just like yeah it's a lot to play it's
not possible when you're in the
honeymoon i'm about to be 50 so i got to
get her pregnant quick so we going right
away
yeah but also have sex also not on the
honeymoon yeah of course but why don't
you uh i think we want to but i like
wow
what else you got nick that's it that's
it wow that went fast how long did we do
we did four hours really we did four
hours of anal talk
night yeah we didn't
we didn't do four hours of anal talk all
we're saying is when it your chicks on a
period disgusting like first of all like
was your chick just like a gusher is she
just like
wow you know wow yeah you made it gross
it's unbelievable you have a real dad
you have a real doctor
wait is it like is she like niagara
falls gross dude here hold on you you
have to know you take it the next level
like that and it's not working it's not
even what you're saying it's not even
what you're saying
you know about sound effects
that's so
he'd gross doing this [ __ ] over like a
tuna sandwich it's so gross
just [ __ ]
yeah you're gross bro yeah too much no
but this episode's called too much
all right anyways uh where are we at i
mean i'm in uh michigan this weekend
speaking of great dude anyway dude bags
of [ __ ] and [ __ ] gush out of your
[ __ ] i'll be in michigan
[Laughter]
i'll be at grand rapids come check me
out this weekend speaking of cold speed
yeah it's gonna be cold as hell but i
get to bust out my uggs and my big
jacket
oh wow okay nope
i got one of those like new york wrapper
jackets you know what i mean they have
the fur right here yeah [ __ ] yeah
hell yeah yeah what do you got coming up
i actually this comes out this week
right thursday night yeah i'll be in
oxnard california well you're there next
weekend though no i'm here this weekend
that's this weekend yeah i'm on those
shows this weekend yeah okay
so you'll come i'll be there yeah
i wanted to be there set up and ready
for some reason
no next weekend is when we are doing
the fight companion yes yep and that's
your show so you should know that i know
you're right when you're right you're
right so and then so that's friday
saturday uh and sunday on sunday you
won't be there sunday won't be the same
daddy doesn't work sunday i'm gonna do
it sunday yep okay so your friday
saturday sunday oxnard yeah levity live
levity live and then also i'll be in uh
san diego the next two weeks just go to
my website chrisley.com we're in san
diego i'm doing that factory oh yeah
i've never done it i didn't know they
had
it's awesome it's got a low ceiling and
[ __ ] we've never been there so yeah uh
and then uh congratulations podcast is
my podcast and then uh i think it's
january 26 chin i'm at the improv shop
and friends
some of the friends in here will be
there it's one show only 8pm again uh
just doing spots all around la for all
of january and then february we have uh
sacramento punchline
and i think we have also wise guys salt
lake city the week before i love that
yeah there you go that's it man love you
guys thanks tune in thanks
[Music]
you know how guys do it so just tune in
for the laughs theo said that he was on
his way but ran out of gas
stevie weeby used to wrestle down at paw
way
now he only finished boys in the hallway
this ain't the
[Music]
just walked in and got it lit you can't
forget about brendan he still need
everything dick dick they still got the
bees and the trap trapping still the
king in the sting so quit asking if you
know then you know it's a cat's thing
ball and chain hair swang like the rat
can king and the stink
back with the crew we got stevie weeby
eric griffin brendan theo too yeah you
know how we do it so just tune in for
the laughs theo said that he was on his
way but ran out of gas
[Music]
[Applause]
king and the sting